hello guys and welcome to another video
in this video i have an update regarding
the upcoming love and thunder trailer so
apparently the trailer is close to
completion if not already done should be
on its way soon i would guess the super
bowl but going off ant-man 2's pattern
possibly the 31st of jan he then makes
an update post saying actually you know
what i'm seeing valentine's day more and
more like a possibility now in my honest
opinion i do think the trailer will
release on valentine's day which is the
14th of february so that's only a few
weeks away and if you're thinking why i
think of release on this day well we
have heard from taika mattini that love
and thunder will be a love story and
even in the title of the movie you have
the word love so i think releasing the
trailer for love and thunder on
valentine's day would be the perfect
time now we know in the past marvel have
released their content such as trailers
for movies associated with a day with
the theme of the movie so for example
for moonlight they've released that
trailer on a day where it was a full
moon where the moon was at a hundred
percent illumination now this could just
be a scenario of overthinking and it
could just be a big coincidence but
marvel is known for doing these things
so i would say the best bet is we'll see
the trailer on valentine's day now as i
said previously it's only a few weeks
away so if it is true in the trailer of
releases then then i am quite excited
because i'm really hyped for this film
tycoortini has hyped this up movie a lot
by saying it might be the best marvel
film ever crimshensworth has even called
it one of the best scripts he's read in
years he told entertainment tonight if
you take ragnarok which i feel was a
very big outlandish bombastic film we're
trying to double down on everything we
did with that and create something
that's more crazy more fun and even more
of a big big adventure taika also talked
to the sydney moore herald about the
movie and indicated there may not be a
fifth film i think this might be funnier
he said everything we did with ragnarok
we've just multiplied it who knows if we
do another one after this but i
definitely feel like we've put
everything every idea and every single
ridiculous concept or gag or stunt or
character into this film i couldn't be
happier with it he later teased that
this film is the craziest thing he's
done to wyatt hinton what i wanted to do
from the beginning was to ask what are
people expecting the least from this
franchise or i know a full-blown love
story now taikawatini always delivers so
i couldn't be more excited for this
movie anyway what do you guys think
about this when do you think we'll see
the trailer for love and thunder do you
think we see it on valentine's day let
me know in the comment section below and
if you haven't already please like and
subscribe and turn notifications on to
show your support thanks for watching